[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's his own
worst enemy like doctor strange and in
the wake of what if episode 4 i have a
brand new theory about what could be
happening in the mcu the entry sets up a
potential big bad in the marvel universe
and it is possible that this guy is
actually the one behind it all yes for
real this time it's not not those other
guys it's really him for real this time
i swear now throughout this video we'll
be going over the theory as well as
discussing some of the leaks on in the
multiverse of madness there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you don't want
anything ruined then i recommend you
destroy your entire reality yes i'm that
serious if you enjoyed the video then
please smash the thumbs up button and
make sure you subscribe for breakdowns
like this each and every day without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our doctor strange
supreme theory
okay so episode four of what if
introduces us to one of the darkest
characters we've ever come across in the
mcu in the multiverse we meet a version
of doctor strange that lost the love of
his life rather than the use of his
hands grief stricken and obsessed with
bringing her back we watch the origin
story for strange supreme in which the
character destroys his entire reality in
order to achieve his goals it's
absolutely heartbreaking and in the end
though all seems lost we do know that
the character will be returning down the
line at some point the trailers have
already shown him meeting captain carter
and therefore we know that he hasn't
been doomed to float through the endless
void on a desolate purple rock seems fun
it really does now i think it is safe to
assume though that due to his vast
abilities that he will be able to break
out of this and travel across the
multiverse in doing so he'll not only
have access to the other realities and
what if but also the main mcu timeline
this is where the second part of our
theory comes into play and that is that
he will actually be the one who's
influencing wander to act a certain way
according to plot leaks on in the
multiverse of madness she will actually
be the villain of the piece and one
division very much teased towards this
in the post-credits scene of episode 9.
in it we could catch wonder looking
through the darkhold attempting to find
a way to improve her powers though we
don't know her full motives yet i think
it's safe to assume that she's looking
for a way to enhance her abilities so
that her children can be brought back to
life in the one division finale we
watched as they ceased to exist with the
collapse of the hex and therefore it
does seem likely that wonder would want
to find a way to improve her powers to
keep them alive forever i am going to be
breaking this down in more detail but
just to add some more context to the
clip let's play the post credits scene
so that we can see exactly what's going
on
okay so as you can hear wanda's kids
scream out and they beg for help this
makes me think that someone has them and
as we know it isn't agatha as she's now
trapped in her own personal hell which
is almost as bad as 2021. now at the
time of the episode's release it was
theorized that this could be a number of
people including mephisto and also
cathon in case you don't know katharine
was the author that created the darkhold
and he did this below wondergall
mountain it is possible that this is
what wonder was sat in front of during
the post-credits scene and other ties to
the character included that he once
possessed quicksilver however after
watching what if i think it's possible
that it's actually strange supreme
that's doing it all if wanda has managed
to hear her children's cries but they
don't exist in this timeline then it's
likely that she's tapped into another
reality this could be one that strange
supreme has access to as well and he
could be sending out bait so that she
pulls him into a reality that he hasn't
destroyed strange of course had access
to the library of cagliostro and it is
possible that when he was there that he
also read up on the darkhold as well as
the interdimensional spells that it
carries thus once wanda opens it and
begins to study it herself there could
be a way to reach out through it into
other dimensions so that he can pull
himself across now though it wasn't
really brought across to this episode
cagliostro was a big villain in the
marvel universe and his books contained
just as many evil spells as they did
good being in his library for however
long he was might have been just as
corrupting to strange as reading the
books themselves and it does make sense
that he would have had access to darker
text such as the darkhold
no wonder in strange also share a lot of
similarities and just in the same way
that she was driven by the grief of
losing vision strange was driven by the
grief of losing christine add to this
the fact that she has lost her children
and i think that the pair would be able
to find some common ground in which
strange could manipulate her into doing
his bidding christine is of course still
alive in the main mcu timeline and
though he seemed accepting of his loss
at the end we know that he was willing
to destroy reality to get here therefore
it just makes a lot of sense to me that
he would try anything to be back with
her and the only person that could truly
stop him is doctor strange thus he could
manipulate wonder into opening the
multiverse for him to travel across and
also drive the idea into her head that
she needed to kill him in order to
protect her kids i think this would make
for an incredible story and as an
audience member you'd easily be able to
sympathize with all sides of the
struggle although wonder is being put
across as the big bad of that film i
think it would be an even bigger twist
if it was actually the alternate version
of strange who was the true enemy the
film is going to be called in the
multiverse of madness and this is
actually a play on at the mountains of
madness by h.p lovecraft in that an
expedition to antarctica unearthed a
hidden darker world beneath the surface
of ours that was lined with creatures
called shoggoths like strange these
hideous beasts absorbed everything they
came across and they could assume any
form potentially the way that we see him
in the final act is hinting towards this
as we can see that strange is now a
monster that can shape shift and turn
into all manner of creatures therefore
the title could be hinting towards
what's really going on i think it would
just make the film far more intense if
we see the mc version of strange taking
on a version of himself that we know has
already defeated other iterations of the
character he could attempt to absorb
strange that he can return to somewhat
of a normal form and this will allow him
to restart his relationship with
christine once more i think wanda would
also be the perfect tool for this as she
too is grief stricken and extremely
powerful however putting this twist in
place also gives her a way out as i
think that she could be forgiven if it
turned out there was someone evil
manipulating her either way strange
supreme is an incredible character and i
really hope that we get a live action
version of him at some point benedict
cumberbatch is of course an amazing
actor and watching him flex both the
light and dark side of strange in a film
would really add a completely different
level to the multiverse of madness it
would also allow for a big twist at the
end and since watching the episode i
can't help but think that strange
supreme might actually be behind a lot
more than we currently know now
obviously i would love to hear your
thoughts on this theory and if you agree
with me or not comment below and let me
know and just to let you know we are
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the zack
snyder dc trilogy on the 30th of
september all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the theory
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now say that to
you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want someone else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of episode 4 which will be
linked on screen right now we've gone
over the full plot of the episode did a
big recap bit of a review and also
pointed out some of the ties to the
movie so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if not then
thank you for singing through this video
i've been paul you being the best and
i'll see you next time take care peace